[Music]
if you're building a social media or
chat app having real-time user presence
is very likely a critical feature
fortunately the firebase real-time
database makes it very easy to determine
whether or not a client is connected to
the database in today's video we'll use
this functionality to build a present
system that will show whether a user is
online offline or way if you're new to
the channel I can subscribe and make
sure to follow along with the full
source code on fire ship IO the first
thing that I want to point out is that
there are a lot of different edge cases
when building a presence system in
today's video we'll look at five
different situations that the user can
be in if they're signing and using the
app they should be online if they're
signed in but the app is closed they'll
be offline but if they're only on a
different browser tab then we'll just
set the status to away then in scenario
number four the user might be signed out
but still have the app open in which
case the connection will still be active
because firebase tracks the connection
to the device and not the authentication
state and if they're signed out in the
app is closed and of course the status
should be offline now let's take a look
at the database model that we'll use for
this we're in the real time database and
we have a note called status then for
each user will create a node based on
their user ID which contains the status
itself and also a timestamp for when it
was changed now let's look at how we
consume this data from the front-end
application on the Left we have the
actual user and then on the right we
just have an incognito browser to
observe the changes in the state when we
log in on the left you'll see that the
browser on the right also gets an
updated status for the user if these are
on the Left then switches to a different
browser tab the status will update to
away I just had to check my myspace for
a minute but when I flip back it will
immediately go back to online now if I
close the browser tab on the left it
will set my status to offline even
though I didn't technically sign out so
the general idea here is that we're
listening to state changes to the users
connection to the database as well as
their authentication state and then
updating the database in response to
those events and you may have noticed
that we're using the real-time database
and not firestorm that's because
presence is not currently supported in
firestore hopefully it is in the future
but for right now you can set up a cloud
function to mirror this data in fire
store if you really need it there
now we're going to jump into the code
but first he should have angularfire
installed in your angular project and
it's also a good idea to have a user
authentication system in place I'll show
all the relevant code in this video but
if you haven't already watch
one of my previous user off videos I
recommend doing that first the first
thing I'm going to do is generate a
service called presence and this will
handle all the business logic for this
feature if we go into the app module you
can see that we're importing angularfire
auth and the angular fired database I
have fire store in here as well but
that's not necessary for this feature
then the last setup thing I'll do is
generate a component called user which
will consume the actual status from the
database and handle the presentation
logic in the UI the bulk of the work
will be done in the service so let's go
ahead and start there first we'll import
angularfire auth and the database and
then we have a few things here from rxjs
that you'll see in use here in a minute
and just as a reference I've commented
in the 5 different states that the user
might be in from there we'll go down to
the constructor and will inject
angularfire auth and the database and
we'll set up a few global subscriptions
here we'll define these in just a minute
but basically we're going to listen to
the users off state we're also going to
listen to an on disconnect hook which
allows us to determine when the user has
disconnected from the database and we'll
also determine if the app is visible
using the browser's visibility API in
order to maximize reusability and
readability I'm going to break
everything down into a couple of small
methods the first one is get presents
which is just wrapping the database
object observable so we can listen to
the user status based on their user ID
the next one is get user which is just
wrapping the angularfire off state but
returning it as a promise this is really
useful when you have a lot of updates to
do because you can use async/await in
your methods we just take the off state
observable pipe in the first operator to
complete the observable and then convert
it to a promise the next method will
perform the actual database write to set
the presence it will take the status
which is either online offline or away
and then the first thing that we'll do
is get the current user based on the off
state if the user is logged in then
we'll go ahead and make a reference to
that object in the database and then
we'll perform an update on it with the
new status it's also a good idea to set
up a timestamp here so you know when the
last status changed you could just use a
JavaScript date here but then that
timestamp won't be consistent across all
of your clients what we'll do instead is
set up a getter to get the firebase
server validates to set the timestamp
server-side so you're not relying on
your clients JavaScript date to set it
now we're going to start writing out the
methods that can actually perform the
date to the status reactively the first
one is update on user and it's primarily
responsible for setting the online
status the real-time database has a
special location called info / connected
which will return a boolean true or
false if a device is connected we'll
take this initial value in the map it to
online if it's true or offline if it's
false so now we can determine if a
device is online or offline but we need
to connect it to a user ID for that
we're going to listen to the angularfire
off state then we'll pipe in switch map
and if the user is logged in then we'll
go ahead and return that connection
observable otherwise we'll just say
they're offline so the end result here
is an observable that tells us whether
or not a log end-users device is
connected to the database but we also
want to perform a side effect here so
we'll use the rxjs tap operator when the
status changes we'll go ahead and update
it in the database and we can use our
set presence method we defined earlier
so that takes care of the online status
now let's take a look at how we can use
the page visibility API in the browser
to determine the away status this is a
very simple API that will just tell us
whether or not the document is visible
now my implementation here is very
simple and there's a lot of things you
could do to make this more sophisticated
but basically it works like this if the
user has the app open but the actual
document is not visible like they're on
a different browser tab then it will set
the status to away so we'll set up a
method here called update on a way and
it will set an event handler for the
unvisible to change event in the browser
now keep in mind that I am touching the
Dom directly here so this code will only
work on the web platform when the
visibility changes we'll go ahead and
check if the visibility is hidden if it
is hidden and we'll set the status to
away otherwise we'll set it to online
that was incredibly easy so let's go
ahead and move on to the most difficult
part which is setting the offline status
the first thing you probably want to do
is update your Sign Out method if you
have one to set the presents to offline
when the user signs out a user might
sign out but still have a database
connection so we want to make sure that
we set them to offline when they do
manually sign out now the cool thing
about the real-time database is that it
gives us a hook called on disconnect
that we can use to run an update after
the actual app has been closed normally
that's not something that's easy to do
in JavaScript because you can't really
run code after the users close the
window but the firebase SDK can do this
with its offline magic we need to
re-register this hook every time the
authentication state changes
in other words we're going to queue up a
database update with the user ID
whenever the database is disconnected so
we'll make this observable dependent on
the angularfire off state then we'll use
the tap operator to queue it up so we'll
say if we have a user
we'll make a reference to that user
object in the database then we'll say a
query ref on disconnect and we can
attach an update to this hook so we'll
just say update the status to offline
and then give it a new timestamp and
remember this method is returning an
observable so make sure that you
subscribe to it somewhere such as the
constructor of this service so that
takes care of all the business logic for
our present system now we just need a
component to actually consume the data
and show some UI elements before we get
to that I recommend injecting the
present service in the app component
constructor this is most likely a global
service that you want to be available
everywhere so this will just make sure
that it's instantiated when your app is
initialized from there we'll go into our
user component and we'll give it an
input variable of UID so you can pass in
a user ID and have it query the status
from the database so a common use case
might be you have a user and that user
has an array of friends on their
document and you loop over that array of
user IDs and show the presence for each
one of them and we've already defined
the logic to get the actual status for a
user so all we have to do is go into ng
on an it then call get presence with the
user ID that's passed into this
component presence will be an observable
of that user status so we can unwrap
that in the HTML with the async pipe and
then we'll set it as a template variable
called presence for right now we'll just
show the status again that'll be online
offline or away but you could also use
the timestamp to determine when the user
was last active this is also a really
good use case for the ng class directive
and angular this will allow us to use a
different CSS class based on the user
status it takes an object and the key of
that object is a CSS class then the
value or the right side is an expression
that should resolve to true or false so
we'll show a green background when
they're online a yellow background when
they're away and a red background when
they're offline that takes care of the
component now you can put it to use
somewhere in your application when you
have the user ID in the context if you
want to show the current status to the
logged in user you might pass in the UID
like this or when you're testing it's
useful to just hard code the user ID in
the component that way you can just open
up an incognito browser and look at the
state changes from the perspective of a
diff
user you can imagine how difficult
building a real-time present system
would be without something like firebase
managing real time state between the
client and server is very challenging
but we managed to get a flexible yet
reliable system up and running in just a
few minutes I'm gonna go ahead and wrap
things up there make sure to grab the
source code from fire ship IO thanks for
watching and I will talk to you soon
[Music]